hi everyone in this video we're going to
talk about folic acid which is vitamin
b9 folic acid came from the name folium
only a means live of vegetables and we
would know that leafy vegetables are the
key source of this vitamin let's talk
about the chemistry of folic acid for a
bit more details so folic acid has three
different chemical residues first the
pate reading dream then a benzoic acid
moiety or parabens weak acid moiety and
at the last there is glutamic acid
residues so this is the overall
structure or the chemical structure of
the folic acid now the folic acid or the
folate is always associated with several
residues of glutamate because in this
format they are more soluble and all the
natural sources of folic acids include
leafy vegetable some grainy vegetables
etc now folic acid is absorbed in the
jejunum of the intestine but holy cow
seen in its glutamate BOM poly glutamate
bound form cannot be absorbed so poly
glutamate form has to be chopped off in
order to be observed absorbed properly
in the intestine the motive mono
glutamate form would be ready to absorb
now once it is absorbed in the
intestinal intestinal lumen why are they
interested in epithelia it is then
converted to tetrahydrofolate by THF
reductase otherwise sometimes this folic
acid once absorbed is transported to the
liver conjugated with glowing and
vitamin E later in the liver the folate
or the folic acid is converted to
dihydrofolate and tetrahydrofolate
sequentially and reductase enzymes with
the help of NADPH carry out this kind of
reactions
let me tell you that folic acid or
folate is an important metabolite or
important compound that helps in
thymidine sensitive synthesis DNA
methylation DNA synthesis and many more
specially one-carbon reactions
one-carbon reactions are triggered by
bullet or the derivatives of folate
so that is why bullet is so important in
terms of biochemical function of the
body now let's talk about what are the
manifestations are fully deficiency
starting from development our neural
tube close and thereby our brain starts
developing but if we have deficiencies
in full it the anterior portion of the
neural tube might not fold lead to
anencephaly that means the baby is born
without a cerebral cortex or without
Attilan Cephalon and eventually it dies
and if the posterior part of the neural
tube does not close properly it leads to
diseases like spina bifida that is why
it is recommended to have 400 micrograms
folic acid daily during pregnancy and
the necessity and the demand of folic
acid increased during pregnancy [ __ ]
acid has also role in terms of electro
site development because let's look at
how any through site develops inside the
bone marrow there are hematopoietic
pluripotent stem cell from there in a
sequential step a retro blaster is
produced and that different sheets into
erythrocyte in case of fully different
folic acid deficiency or folate
deficiency a metabiotic stem cell give
rise to macro sites which are immature
version of these RBC and look pretty
much spherical instead of that
characteristic dumbbell shaped now these
macro sites are useless mostly they are
degraded in the spleen just to
compensate that the metabolic
pluripotent stem cell different sheets
into megablast
megalo blasts or these mega lo blasts
are immature versions of these RBC and
much useless now other than that
hematopoietic pretty potent stem cells
also give rise to my light progenitors
which can give rise to neutrophils but
in case of folic acid deficiency there
are hyper segmented neutrophils which
are produced and it's a key
characteristic of folic acid deficiency
then question is how can select acid
deficiency or benign deficiency can
occur it can occur due to lack of leafy
greens in your diet it can also occur
due to lack of absorption or a problem
in the absorption process in the jejunum
and this lap of absorption can be due to
over alcoholism or many medicines that
you're taking now let's see the visible
symptoms or visible biomarkers of folate
deficiency first thing which is affected
at the mucosa for example the mucosa on
your tongue or in your lips so many
times you have seen you have bitten your
tongue accidentally but it heals in one
or two days pretty rapid right but when
it is for the deficiency this healing
process is delayed and you can see
blemishes inside your lips or inside
your tongue this might be one visible
symptom of folate deficiency and this
persist for a long time this is out of
these kind of eptas ulcers are one of
the reason or one of the consequence of
folate deficiency not exclusive now the
question is how we can detect folate
deficiency one of the tests or what are
the available diagnostic measures we
have we know that fully derivative tetra
hydro flora folate is very important for
homocysteine conversion to methionine so
homocysteine gets converted to
methionine with the help of methyl THF
and that is out the methyl THF donates
its methyl group so it's a 1 carbon
metabolism that is going on we'll be
talking about 1 carbon metabolism later
in details but ultimately produce tea
but when there is a deficiency in folate
as we can understand that methyl THF
won't be available as a result
homocysteine won't be converted to
Matheny and when homocysteine is not
getting converted to methionine
homocysteine level increases in the
blood and as a result it could be also
excreted in the urine and forming the
situation called homocysteine urea so
detecting homocysteine in the urine is
one of the key diagnostic measure of
this fluid deficiency other than this
peripheral blood smear test can also
detect the deficiency of vitamin b9
because we would have megaloblastic
macrocytic anemia in case of folate
deficiency in the peripheral blood smear
test we can understand at least
visualize the hyper segmented neutrophil
and the large and oval roundish RBC's
which are bigger than the normal RBC's
this is how the folate deficiencies can
be determined so I hope this video was
useful if you like this video the video
a thumbs up don't forget to Like share
and subscribe thank you